dear marshall vozniak thank you for the
invitation and your pioneering
leadership in clean hydrogen
but before i address europe's energy
transition
i would like to take a moment to thank
every polish citizen
for their extraordinary support to the
people of ukraine
your entire country is mobilized to help
brave ukrainian people
and those who have lost so much
you are showing the best of europe
distinguished guests from across our
european union
dear representatives of the republic of
korea and the united arab emirates
already before russia's barbaric attack
on ukraine we knew
that we needed to move away from fossil
fuels to a more sustainable economy
this transition will provide us not just
with abundant and affordable clean
energy
but also with energy security
green hydrogen is essential to end
europe's dependence
on an unreliable and dangerous supplier
such as russia
and that is why in our new plan
we power eu
we have doubled our 2030 target
to produce annually 10 million tons
renewable hydrogen in the european union
and we shall also import another 10
million tons from abroad
this can replace up to 50 billion cubic
meters per year of imported russian gas
today
you are meeting in a place that shows
how this transition to hydrogen is not
only possible
but profitable
el kapolska is showing the way to all
regions
in europe and the world
whose economy relies on coal mining
since 2018 via kopalska has been working
hard to become one of the first hydrogen
valleys in europe
your 2030 plan is already bearing fruit
we see an entire ecosystem emerging
solar wind and biomass are replacing
coal-fired power plants
clean energy is then turned into clean
hydrogen
and that hydrogen is used to power heavy
industry
or to hit homes
like the innovative housing estate in
pila
and to fuel mobility
in fact the first fleet of hydrogen
buses
is coming to poland this year
as of next year these buses will be
built here locally
with a target of 100 vehicles per year
and this means many more local jobs
and programs like hydrogen school are
giving workers the skills to take up
those jobs
including those men and women who come
from generations of hard-working coal
miners
your example shows
what the european green deal can do
it is farsighted industrial policy
it is europe's growth strategy
and it creates good jobs not only here
in poland
across the union regions are building
hydrogen ecosystem like yours in fact
i'm convinced that your example can
inspire many others
and it should because we need to expand
the european hydrogen economy as a
matter of urgency
today i'm here to say
the european commission is your partner
in
this so let me explain three actions we
are taking to accelerate the hydrogen
transition
first we are giving the industry the
predictability you need
second with massive public investment
and third
through our alliance with the private
sector and advanced research
so let me start with predictability
tomorrow the commission is adopting a
regulatory package for green hydrogen
then the main regulatory parameters will
be in place
for the completion of an integrated gas
and hydrogen infrastructure
including storage
and port infrastructure
we have set in europe the targets for
2030 and now we deliver the rules of the
game
thus the hydrogen industry has now
all the clarity it needs to plan for the
future
so all our regional ecosystems
can merge into a truly european hydrogen
market
and what has began in europe in our
regions
will become a competitive global market
a clean and lucrative hydrogen market
led by europe and its partners
that in the decades to come
will replace the global market for dirty
fossil fuels
with the current rise in gas prices
green hydrogen can already be cheaper
than grey hydrogen
our target is
to bring its cost below 1.8 euros per
kilo by 2030
and this goal is within reach
because the investments are coming
i'm talking about both public investment
and much greater private investment
which we can unlock
and this is my second point
we have to scale up clean hydrogen
production
expand its applications
and create a virtuous cycle
where demand and supply feed each other
and bring the prices down
our recovery plan next generation eu
is worth 800 billion euros in current
prices over four years
and over one third of this
will finance the goals set in the
european green deal
to ensure sufficient renewable
electricity to produce renewable
hydrogen
9.3 billion euros from next generation
eu are going straight into hydrogen
projects and this is just the beginning
the commission is assessing state aid
for hydrogen projects
as a priority
our so-called
important projects of common european
interest
so in short ipcei
on hydrogen
shall be approved by the summer
and this will kick start large
industry-driven investments which are
worth well over 50 billion euros
hydrogen is a perfect example of what
public private partnership can achieve
your region is a pioneer here as well
with cooperation between the public
sector
industry and academia
it is the same concept that has inspired
our european clean hydrogen alliance
because our entire hydrogen transition
is about cooperation
as the next step we recently launched
the new clean hydrogen partnership
it will add 1 billion euros to research
and innovation
matched by another 1 billion from
industry
it will bring innovative technologies
from the laboratory to the factory floor
and ultimately to european businesses
and consumers
this is how we can build together
a european hydrogen economy
we have the targets
we are building a market
the investment is there
and regions are making it happen
green hydrogen is not just a huge
commercial opportunity
green hydrogen is good for the planet
green hydrogen is good for energy
security
and energy security
is an important pillar of our european
independence
thank you very much for having me